so let's think about what happens when
we multiply by ten and see if we can see
some type of a pattern so let's just
start with one and multiply by multiply
that 1 by 10 and this of course is equal
to 10 well you knew that already but
let's multiply it by 10 again so let's
do 1 times 10 and now let's multiply by
another 10 let's multiply by another 10
so what's this going to be this is going
to be 1 times 10 which is 10 and then
that 10 times 10 so it's literally 10
tens or 100 now let's multiply by 10
again so we're going to have 1 times 10
times 10 times 10 times times 10 what is
this going to be equal to well we
already know that 1 times 10 times 10 is
100 and then we're going to multiply
that times 10 again so we're going to
literally have ten 100's which we know
is the exact same thing as 1,000 so
what's the pattern here well here we
multiplied by 10 once and we have one
zero here we multiplied by 10 twice and
we have two zeros here we multiplied by
10 three times and we have three zeros
in our answer let's do it again although
it looks like a pretty clear pattern
let's multiply by ten four times so
we'll start with the one well multiply
by 1/10 that's our first 10 then our
second 10 then our third 10 and now our
fourth 10 well what's this going to be
equal to well it's going to be this
thing this thing times 10 tiya or this
thing I should say times 10 or a
thousand times 10 which is 10 thousands
so let me write that 10 10,000 so once
again we started with a 1 we multiplied
by 10 4 times and we got 10,000 one
followed by one two three four zeros let
me make that clear we start with the one
we multiplied by 10 one two three four
times
and our product is one followed by one
two three four zeros so I think you see
the pattern here but there might be
something you're craving you're like hey
Sal this is a pain to do this repeated
and multiplication I wish there was some
type of operation that just did it for
us the same way that back in the day
when you were doing repeated addition
where if you were saying ten plus ten
plus ten plus ten you said hey this is
the same thing as four times ten
there should be another thing for
repeated multiplication if I have one
times 10 times 10 times 10 times 10
which is really the same thing as taking
four tens and multiplying them together
because the 1 doesn't change the value
so 10 times 10 times 10 times 10 you're
saying hey there should be some type of
shorthand for this and you're right
there is some type of shorthand for this
and it's called an exponent so the same
way if you take 4 tens and add them up
that's the same thing as 4 times 10 if
you take 4 tens and take their product
this is the same thing as 10 to the
fourth power 10 to the fourth power
literally takes means taking four tens
and multiplying them together or you
could view it as starting with a 1 and
multiplying by 10 4 times so this is
also equal to 10 to the fourth power
this right over here we started with 1
we multiplied by 10 3 times which is the
same thing as taking three tens and
multiplying them together this is 10 to
the third power
this right over here is 10 squared or 10
to the second power and this right over
here we just have 1 10 right over here
we just started with the one we
multiplied by 10 once this is 10 to the
first power and just so you know a
little bit of the terminology here 10 is
our base the base is 10 and this for
this for that we have right over here
this is the exponent the exponent so
given that notation let's just do one
practice let's figure out let's the
about what I'll do new colors what 10 to
the 6th power is and I encourage you to
pause the video and think about it well
there's two ways to think about it you
could view this as taking tes six tens
so 10 10 10 10 10 and 10 and multiplying
them together so we multiply them all
together or you could view it as
starting with a 1 and multiplying it by
10 6 times but either way what are you
going to get well if you're multiplying
one by 10 6 times you're going to end up
with one followed by six zeros we
already saw this pattern so it's going
to be 1 followed by 1 2 3 4 5 6 zeros or
1 million so 10 to the 6th power is the
same thing as 1 being multiplied by 10 6
times or taking 6 tens and multiplying
them together and that's going to be
equal to one followed by six zeros which
is this pattern we saw or 1 million